[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
team
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right can you guys hear me
all right can you guys hear me
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys man what's
going on
i think you guys can hear me fine you
should be able to i don't know
sometimes uh this youtube thing's weird
i'm not seeing me okay there we go there
we go we did pop up
let me minimize my screen just a little
bit i don't need to be that big
there we go that should be better
do not need to be half the screen
let me see how it looks i had to go get
some
propels to do this stream
make sure i'm able to uh
to survive
up silver what's going on guys
all right so when i first got the the
playstation i did
pretty much start an account i think i'm
like literally like
10 minutes in the game i don't know
where you guys
exp uh so i am showing you this i get to
like i got to like the very beginning i
didn't get far at all
because i just wanted to see what the
game looked like so that was like my
biggest priorities to see what the game
looked like
and then i planned on restarting because
i think
literally you started the game at the
beginning of this bridge
so do you guys want me to start over
completely or start from here
it's up to you guys man
oh no no the uh you i you guys missed
where i got destroyed by that first dude
i have you know i'm going to start over
i'm going to start over because
part of me wants to be see if
i can do anything that one do
all right so let's start over let's
start over
addict we got to be we got to have the
the tradition addict man
you know what's funny it's just tutorial
before this
i mean a lot of people want to restart
uh because i think i'm going to restart
uh soldier knight now
the soul level i don't really know what
the soul level is
uh i guess that's like magic builds
royalty person who wrote to you who
learns spells
especially that protects the temple of
god i have no clue what any of these are
i feel like these two right here man
this is where i'm at right now these two
right here and i'm leaning towards
i'm leaning towards knight finish the
game on one life
ah no no thank you no thank you we ain't
doing that
i think i'm going to go with the knight
starting gift
i don't know exactly what any of these
are kunai firebomb soul remains
serve as a bait for soul starter fire
arrow
elixir
a kunai do i get these for good or these
just
or are these just is there a peasant
no i don't see a peasant one
i'm gonna i'm gonna go with i don't know
do i get any of these do i get to keep
them or are they just gone the moment i
throw them because that's gonna really
determine what i pick
are you gonna be playing the whole game
across multiple episodes probably
the ring yeah yeah i could see that i
discovered all right all right yeah i
see that i do that foundation appearance
i don't really care what i look like i
like this one though
do they animation hold up
yeah let's just do that
i guess i'm a chick i don't know how
that happened
i mean i guess it doesn't matter because
at the end of the day
like i'm gonna have armor on the whole
game
let's just start with this let's just
start with this not if she was
slandering the chat i think
oh okay okay okay so i'm gonna start
with this
whatever this is king alant the twelfths
by channeling the power of souls brought
unprecedented prosperity
to his northern kingdom of boletaria
that
is until the colorless deep fog
swept across the land
now how does my cam look do i look fine
on the cam itself
like the green screen is messing up a
little right here i think i don't know
which side of me it's on
it's probably the opposite so it's this
side here but for the most part it
doesn't look like
horrible and told the world of
boletaria's plight
at the old king
i've already heard this i know people
probably want to hear this but i've
already heard this when i started would
you have played the journal of nexus
i don't know what that is we ain't what
we play no journal all right we
we doing this from the start
you have died so i guess
i guess since i started that i can't i
can't do the first part over
again
or is the journal me dying
is the journal me dying i think the
journal is me dying
but do i do you guys really want to see
me get destroyed by what's his name so i
guess it doesn't really matter at that
point
all right that's that's what's up that's
what i'm making sure man making sure
can't
out here looking suspect which i already
look suspect most the time but i can't
be looking suspect
all the time
we are live
i'm still gonna fight this dragon this
dragon looks kind of intimidating i'm
not gonna even try to front you guys
so yeah i pretty much started exactly
where i was
oh look how slow i'm rolling
i'm chunky how'd that happen
i don't like being sh oh i like that
animation
this crescent moon grass what is that
i'm assuming it's healing items of some
sort
i don't there's like a bunch of healing
items it looks
it looks good you sure okay
look at these little things man
all right all right
is he behind this no
fat roll right out the is there a reason
that i'm rolling fat
like explain to me why i'm fat i picked
the small body type
i do not like this
i don't like being this slow i'm not
gonna lie to you guys being this slow is
not
oh my god i'm using
oh i'm playing quality now okay okay
i'm not getting the the the natural hate
when i play destiny though i guess
that's good
look at this doing the flames
you're gonna tear wear yourself out fam
stop being so predictable
how'd that work for you
what's up dude
true take a helmet or something night
our arm is heavy
oh so it's the armor i picked okay all
right
all right i'm the reason i'm fat got you
got you guys i'm gonna have to fix that
man
is it too late to fix that is it too
late to be skinny
or am i just like this for the rest of
the game
[Music]
is this dude behind me
yeah how'd that work for you
this guy has one but two universities
encumbrance systems oh
okay that that that's amazing
take a helmet off can i take the helmet
off okay
i'm still okay
is it sad i'd rather be naked before i
i'm that slow
yeah i'm gonna be naked
i'ma be naked man i'd rather be naked
than slow
oh he's throwing fire at me what is that
about
i think it needs to be under 50 demons
so starting equipment doesn't really
matter you can change as much as you
want as the game continues
it's game never too late to hit the gym
i'm trying to hit the gym man i've been
going to the gym
i have been going to the gym uh i have
been posting the stuff on twitter
actually i could oh man accidentally hit
the wrong button
i could actually stream to like 6 30
because i gotta
i gotta go to the gym
oh my god like actually attack him i
don't want to do
just take off the helmet but i was still
slow
that's still slow erica do you think i
want to be moving like this
nah i don't think i want to be moving
like this i'd rather be
naked than slow man i'd rather be naked
than slow
ah i don't i i don't feel that i'd
rather be
i'd rather be quick man adjacent
there's someone behind me yes there is
oh take a couple hits can't you
what's his blood stain someone's
throwing some
some some stuff up there i don't like
what i see up there there's something
going ah see look at that
look i scared the [ __ ] out of me
i'm gonna run yolo
okay okay let's let them come down here
to me man
let's let them come down here to me
let's let them come down here to me
my character is heavy look man
i'm not used to being so defensive in
these type of games usually i like being
offensive
all right so he was the one throwing
those i don't get up to him
i got to be able to get up to him
somehow
can i push you off
[Music]
i totally can future reference i can
push them all
how'd that work for you stupid
oh
stop running i will run as much as i
want
all right so hold up my mic's distorted
how is my mic distorted
explain how is my mic distorted is it
too loud
do i need to turn it down okay hold up
what about now
is my mic fine am i able to hear me
i ain't trying to be distorted kevin
said oh it's disorder but it's
entertainment
i ain't trying to do that if my mic's
messed up
people tell me don't just let me go
around with some messed up mike
i don't know how to spartan kick people
can you spartan kick people
oh my god
why ain't that some nonsense
oh what's there
oh it's heavier man i don't like that
it's heavy
we gonna put it on oh hold up hold up
you're not strong enough okay so i need
to
have a 95 in strength it looks like
i got a 14. oh i'm not wearing that for
a while
oh i put it on
nah i gotta be fast man fast and nimble
man fast and nimble that's all that
matters
i i turned it down is that better like i
did turn the
the mic down
oh look at this dude
this dude over here has he got a bow
oh he's definitely got a bow
you've definitely got a bow whisper
look man i i don't need to be whispering
whispering sounds weird man when i
whisper
you don't want to hear that
look at this dude with this spear
all right so i got more
[Music]
i knew i was about to get hit
nothing i could do man i knew i was
about to get
use the new xbox headset no that
headset's mic sounds horrible
you guys want me to use that headset
until you hear it
i have to i have to get a new headset i
didn't know i didn't know my mic was
sounded all messed up
people need to tell me stuff like that
before
yes this game is only playstation only
oh this
oh what is this his little goat armor
he's got a spear oh he's got a lot of
hell
[Music]
come on man what you got
got no got a lot do you look look how
healthy is that
backstab should have killed him
i call repeat repeat
oh he has to be like one time it's it's
a rat
let me get my health back
oh this dude might have me man
how oh my god man
that that dodge is ridiculous i know i
dodged under him i know i dodged under
i call cap there
i call cap there man i know i dodged
that
i'm i'm streaming
i dodge them successfully i don't care
what it says
i don't like that it should let me
attack regularly when i
when i rode
what is the shield yeah that is a good
point what is a shield i don't need no
shield
i got a sword i don't need no skill
i think there's demon souls or something
man this is this is bloodborne 2.0
let's go you guys ain't gonna attack
i'll attack you
come back to that dude later or not he
killed me i gotta kill him
that's how it works eric i don't just i
don't just run
[Music]
look at this dude trying to surround me
[Music]
i hear someone but where is he
oh this dude i didn't see him last time
i'm gonna need you guys to leave me
alone if i want to use
shield or if i don't want to use this
show that's entirely up to me
it's my prerogative
is is it really that serious about using
a shield in this game
i'm getting much with the tower night i
don't know man i don't know what's going
on right now you don't have to
you have to bear with me you got the
bear with me
you got the bay with me oh i know do
your thing
look man
look at this this this viewpoint
is this
[Music]
all right so so is this serious is it
that serious to you to use your shield
in this game
look man see i i i keep when they say
press
x i think i'm on xbox and i press x on
xbox and i'm wasting
items because of it
all right i mean if i'm gonna if i'm
gonna shield i'm just put on
all my armor
let me just put on my armor man also
backstab
oh my god i hate it
is ridiculous how can you even move that
slow
look man i don't like the way you guys
are trying to
trying to play you know what
let me let me take these off so i can
get up to this man's quick
i heard someone oh this is that fire
[Music]
dude
oh what is this
throw your next one throw it
i already know i'm gonna try to enjoy
the ride i feel like
i'm being i feel like i'm being
i'm being set up that's what i feel like
i'm being set up
you guys are not telling me everything
come on comes down here
where i can control the narrative
let's take one at a time
one at a time
look at like the marks on my body
i'm gonna just stick to the shield man i
could just stick to the shield
there's another dude back there if i
remember
am i like weaker now or something
why am i doing less damage
i need to make a new character so i
learned the hard way
my stuff has a damage thing
oh 177 out of 200 i don't like that
guess we're gonna find out the hard way
uh this is where that boulder was wasn't
it that accidentally rolled off
oh no
oh yeah you can you can walk onto them i
forgot about that
you can lock on to them
look man do i really want to play the
way everyone plays door uh dark steven
souls
is it really necessary like am i going
to get destroyed if i don't
am i going to review this game probably
not
the beginning easy man the beginning
well i've already died so
i don't know what that says about me
oh here's this dude again
oh here's here's my souls
all right so [ __ ] look put
put some iop logos
put some crests in chat if i should give
this dude a round two
or should i or should i run from him put
some logos in that chat
if i should fight this dude again
i'm curious if i should fight him i'm
kind of scared he
i was i was a little bit more agile last
time i fought him any any and he
destroyed me man
he hit me like twice and i was dead
don't go this way is it that bad
man you guys don't want it man
i think i should try man oh look at how
salsa like do it
i think it's i think it's been
determined man
do it do it you know what
i'ma do it i'ma do it
let's go man
look at that i'm telling you this game
see how quick i died i had his health
halfway
when i fought him last and you guys say
attic use a shield
attic you use your armor and he killed
me and won
it this is all you this isn't on me
this is on you
listen to the chat they say get killed
they say
[Music]
look at that roll man
that road is ridiculous look at this
like
how do you even roll like that in real
life
it's like it just stops how do you do
that
i need to start reading the chat because
i'm catching myself on fire and
everything
look i i will give it to you that was
probably a little that was a little
hustle
a little bit hustle i shouldn't have
done it
little hustle
look man
i feel like i was stronger and i was
doing more damage
when i was not using a shield i feel
like i'm doing worse
because i'm using a shield i just want
to point that out there
yeah hold that that did hit me like
eight times and it didn't count
look man i gotta give it a
i gotta give a show man i gotta give a
show
i gotta find lighter armor that's what i
gotta do
let's do let's try to get a backstab man
let's get a backstab let's get him away
from that edge
i want him over here where i can have my
way with him
or get caught on fire i got the backstab
though i got the backstab that's all
that matters
another backstab
uh i know but he still sell one of his
series x and get one
uh he doesn't have a he doesn't have a
ps5 anymore i got his ps5 he can't play
something he don't got
and you guys know how kid is you're
gonna have to we're gonna have to get a
a a thing of money together it's gonna
have to be an event
it's the only way he'll play games that
he don't like
[Music]
[Music]
man
i didn't even see him move
go get my souls but my souls is with
that dude
i feel like he's gonna he's gonna thrash
me if i go and get them
you guys feel like i should go get those
souls those souls in a very bad place
man
they're in a really bad place i'm scared
to look at those things
[Music]
there's another dude over here too
you see me smiling through my beard
it's interesting
last time i checked man i went through
how to get this playstation
so i feel like that represents enough
one second
uh
[Music]
sorry about that my brother had to come
and do something
uh go get yourselves he ain't tough he
oh no
no i listened to you guys and i got
demolished i got destroyed
go get your soul
what the hell chain
i'm gonna go get those souls
i might catch on fire too
just enjoy the ride erica you guys are
trolling me man
you guys are trolling me and i can't
upgrade until i get some souls
i still want those souls on erica
i feel like those souls are gonna help
me ascend to the next level
come over here man why aren't you
catching on fire
i knew i was gonna catch on fire man
nothing i could have done that until you
beat the first boss
i think i'm far away from the first boss
come through there
oh
i kind of want my souls i kind of want
them
not going to lie to you guys i want
those souls i feel like those souls are
mine they belong to me
going for those souls those souls belong
to me
look i want those souls erica and you
can't tell me any different
those souls can be very beneficial to me
if i get them
i don't gotta fight the dude i just
gotta grab the shows and run
now i've i i told you because i showed
you guys the only part of this game i
played
look tyrone or you know i can't i can't
pronounce stuff
you guys know this i mean we should know
this by now you know
i do play these games right i've beat
all these games
there's been very few of these souls
type of games i haven't beat
is these my souls
yep see look at me i'm gonna pick them
right up walk the rest away
the other way i'm listening to you guys
man
i'm learning
i got my souls erica i got them i feel
like
well look i personally feel like oh yeah
my
my camera's over here i'm used to my
camera being here but my camera's right
here so i got to get used to that
i am used to the fact that i am
confident if i took off my armor and i
was fast in these streets
that i could kill that dude but the chat
is advising me not to
so i ain't going to do it i'ma listen to
the chat today
today that might not listen to you
tomorrow but i'm gonna listen to the day
is this another one of those dudes
is this another one of those dudes
explain to me why i see another one
oh no this is ain't what this this this
dude can't compare to that other dude
okay he's not kate but he definitely is
not
as agile as the other dude
the other dude was fast man oh you eat
no hell no
do eating man eating some lobster right
in front of me
ow
[Music]
this dude is not eating that lobster in
front of me
[Music]
smash the like button i appreciate if
you guys smash that like button man i
appreciate it
uh i i told cognito i would try to do
more content on the iop channel
normally i do stuff like this play with
that armor i wouldn't last a second man
look look i feel like
me being faster how fast i am with noah
hold up oh this is this is this is the
this is the this is the way
man
but i'm not gonna do that because you
guys
know more about this game than me
i feel like i shouldn't go through the
fog so i check on the why is he fat
rolling already
look i said the same thing i guess it's
because i got this night armor on
i should have picked a different class
maybe
i don't know man
i don't know
really you know what
considering they're never going to get
past that position i'm going to get some
dr
some water
that went differently in my head that
went differently
in my head i'm not gonna lie that one a
little different in my head
just a little bit different
here's another one let's let's guard
like you guys say
never mind i don't have to he fell off
crisis averted he fell off
let's keep going down
i don't like how it's turning more red
the more i go down here
oh god
firebomb
did they die yep
oh i need to stop looking at the chat
is this a lever it's a lever
this is the other side of that place i
bet you hold up we're about to find out
yeah okay so this is the this is the the
shortcut the shortcut
don't waste them
so you guys saying i gotta throw
firebombs in this game too
i don't know if i could stump that low i
don't know if i can stop
go that low
guys want me to really downgrade how i
play these games man i like to be in
your face
i don't like to throw some some fire
bombs i just threw them because i wanted
to see how they work
but you guys tell me to say them like
they're essential and if they sit you
liking that
so i guess you can't break those
anything
fire save it oh god okay so it's a fire
thing
anything fire save it
this game does look really nice i'm
playing it on a monitor though so
there's that it's gonna be good i assume
that i assume that the boss is coming
why am i doing that continuous stat
i don't like that
oh
i got two can you farm these health
things
why don't they hurt each other
oh
because you're using a dagger oh i'm
using a dagger oh i didn't know that
okay okay
okay you guys can uh you you can make
fun of me for that
i didn't know i was using a dagger but
that's perfectly fine
what's that sound
is there someone around this corner
oh what is this good day to you
that's a creepy looking dude mostly
stolen but
who's telling me
oh man these are 100 bucks each
hmm let's just buy some
some health buy
five of these let's buy two of these
so which ones of which
so the crescent one
okay so the this one here is the one
with the little bit
oh god
people got axes and stuff now
switch
oh
oh god
i don't like that speed man
i can't stand being slow i don't like it
being slow is just it's like the worst
thing in the world for me man
that's another one of these dudes here
come down here
let's let's fight down here one on one
man 1v1 me
1v1 me foamy
oh oh he fell
let's go see what he had let's go look
what he had
we need we need we need items man
there we go that's worth it
take off something over to move faster
exam
yo yeah i went back i went back fat mike
i went back
big mike not fat mike
main uh take me an arm off and use the
rest
is there a rest button
look man i don't know
oh someone's trying to hit me off some
more arrows
what's up
that i feel like that hurt it's a little
bit
he's alive oh
that we gotta correct this how did he
fall and live
we gotta correct this we gotta go down
here and handle this
i don't know how you live dude
but we gotta correct it
gotta correct it
look man i i just stared at your name
real fast and i thought it said fat mike
for a second all right
this is big mike
uh what's around this corner
more people oh this is a lot of people
something's going they want me to fight
all these people
oh and there's arrows being shot at me
too
oh my god oh
wow
wow you guys played me you knew that was
about to happen
you played me
i feel a certain way man i felt like i
should have been warned
i got a chat that has knowledge but i
wasn't worn
i don't like that i think i think uh put
put some into the bushes man if there's
any members in there man
you got to celebrate my death this is
demon soul you can't be doing that
gotta celebrate it celebrate the death
of addict on demon souls man you got to
check the environment man
yeah i should have you right
now i don't want hints i was just joking
with you guys
there's a dude right here a dude coming
down
let's do with his little
you will know next time to hit those
rocks we can help or you could choose
violence we choose file
look man then choose violence it's okay
you can choose violence
i'm not dealing with you oh what
happened
i thought that was a shortcut
do they close
that's gay
could have swore that open
[Music]
shortcuts be be glitching and stuff man
what's going on yeah get down with
[Music]
they said
yeah they definitely uh other side go
back
okay oh i [ __ ] hold up hold up
all right that's what's up yeah i was
totally gonna miss that
i missed the shortcut i know i went back
i went back what an
idiot how'd that work for you
hold up
i wonder where this first boss is i feel
like i've i've
traveled a decent amount into this
not a whole lot though
ah
this definitely isn't as long as the
other one but it's still pretty decently
long
i yeah that dude's still there
see what watch
[Music]
[Music]
oh i was close to the first boss
all right i got you guys
oh
oh that's [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
all right i'm done playing around
done playing around
yeah okay
come through here i know there's a bunch
of
come on
i'm ready for blood
i don't want them coming up behind me
no i i'm done i'm done with this
nonsense
these people wanted my serious thought
they could
or i can just mess up and accidentally
press x
okay
there's another one
claims to be done playing around about
to get ganked by mob but did
i did i die kev did i die from the mob
i think not
oh
yeah i'm not gonna come on
i'm not gonna break my dual sense
controller i am not kid
smooth you guys need to calm down on
that nonsense
break my duel since patrolling you
survived while my popcorn was popping
disappointed
look man first off let's have this
jackass throw whatever the hell he wants
to throw
that seems to kill you with one hit if
you let it
i think this is the do with the spear
oh my god
what an idiot
traps yeah there's definitely some traps
man there's no denying that there's
traps
let's go visit this dude again
all right
are you guys saying close to the boss of
this area
wonder how close you mean
is he right around the corner there's
some axe dude
[Music]
oh god
don't think it's okay not close he's
about to run heads out
i don't like i don't like the the
doubting in this chat that i'd be seeing
i don't like the doubt
let me think where did i die last time
i don't know where i died last time
oh yeah it was a stupid boulders that's
right
there's those stupid boulders come down
here
there you go i ain't going up there you
coming down here
we don't play that game
shouldn't have tried that
oh god
all right so here we go pretty sure this
is where i was last time
that went well that time
on the road again
pick this up
this uh
i don't think none of them lived i hope
not
had all those boulders
uh
[Music]
all right let's see here that feels like
a
boss area but this might be a boss area
is there another shortcut around here
i feel like there's another shortcut
around here
oh what is this
yeah dead bodies um i'm not going that
way
well they will they fly away if i get
closer to them
i don't think they will i think they're
gonna burn me alive
i think the dead bodies state they're
gonna burn me alive
more come on
the hell
[Applause]
do i have to fight it right now
okay
i'm scared i'm gonna go the other way i
feel like he's gonna kill me
he's over here again
i feel like the bridge i feel safer on
that bridge like low key
i feel safer on that bridge
that bridge seems like a very risky play
oh god
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
so
is that the same red dragon
yes it is i feel like he's gonna come
back though
man
i feel like this blue one up here about
to kill me man
so he moves around
hmm
look man i'm just curious what side i go
do i go
this way because it looks like
the distance between that is too much
what if i go all the way back to that
the blue dragon
i got a new shield
a purple flame shield
i'm definitely not strong enough to wear
that [ __ ]
i feel like i gotta go that way
all right so you didn't you didn't
trigger him okay
look how he knows when i'm there it's
kind of ridiculous if you think about it
[Applause]
there's still some items over there i
kind of want to
oh
okay so so the blue dragon will knock me
into this next world
good to know
people saying you being scared again
look at that me not being scared i got
i got destroyed
i'm gonna have to to ask you guys to
stop with that nonsense
don't be scared it's just a dragon
just a dragon with with his tail what
can a dragon with this tail possibly do
i don't i don't like how you guys
low-key played me there
i feel like you guys low-key played
i died again
what ring the fire resistant ring
oh my god man
not filling right now man no i don't
think i got the ring
the right ring that you guys are
referring to
no i don't think i got the ring that you
guys are talking about
i don't think i got it man
i might die again but i'm gonna try to
fight these uh people a little bit
differently this time
just
yeah i need i need to take my time going
up that
there's one more spring it's super
important man
like i got destroyed by that blue dragon
i feel like you're trying to troll me
man you're trying to troll me
into going back up there and getting and
getting swiped by that stupid dragon
again
and where is this go i assume another
shortcut
look man i'm a little intimidated man
just a little bit
what time is it what time is it 603 we
got about another 40 minutes man
don't do that dragon again
so did i get everything i needed like i
wonder if the shield
with the ring will give me what i need
to get past that bridge
i think that's not accurate but it might
be
what's up black ronin what's up guys i
appreciate everyone coming by man
had a good 70 strong man it's going to
take me a little bit
a little bit to get used to what's going
on here
the cleaning ring all right so i did get
that but
i do feel like i will eventually drag
onto is it really ready for a dragon
though no
i'm never ready
oh god
oh oh yeah that's right he's the idiot
lorca proves
look man i i see i told you i put the
chat up
which shows you beat so far well erica
trying to
try she she's trying to be like what
souls you beat so far because
look all right
erica i don't appreciate
you validating the bullying man you
you're opening this up to what do you
have the right to play demon souls i
know what's going on
yeah i played demon soul i played dark
souls 1.
i played a lot of dark souls 2 but i
never beat dark souls 2
and i played a little bit of dark souls
3. i played chakra i'll play
bloodborne
which people i didn't like dark souls 2.
i don't know why
something about dark souls 2 didn't
click with me
but i've been told dark souls 3's good
and i've been meaning to go back to it
it's just you guys know how it is once
once a game's behind man
owl
[Music]
all right so they always drive that lat
late moon grass
demon says the easiest souls game
attic plane like smooth blood
look man smooth i've never played d
massage you're gonna have to get off my
back man
i don't know what these oh god
damn it oh
god talking to the chat got me killed
i blame every one of you i blame
you black ronin i blame big mike i blame
erica
i forgot all about that oh yeah the
camera's over here
i'm not saying that again we're just
gonna have to move on
oh my god
ugh
come over here again
i'm so discouraged after that man i'm so
discouraged after that
oh i'm so discouraged i can't believe
that happened
oh
i cannot believe i let that happen again
i learned that two days ago look man
it's gonna take me a minute man it's
gonna take me a bit i'm gonna i'm gonna
get it
something's gonna click might take a
little bit but something will click
i guarantee you something will click
you like that on outriders last night
i really just can get a little a little
bit difficult man
man look at that bull
there's an absurd amount of people here
i didn't mean to eat that but it's okay
we're going to move past that
oh i thought i was gonna i thought that
was gonna explode for a second
i need to repair the sword i don't know
how to repair anything man
i'm repair ignorant i don't know how to
repair anything
i was almost there man
oh i can't believe i let that happen man
i cannot believe i let that happen
i feel like a part of me died with that
character when he exploded those
every time i see the
every time every time i see the sword
hit a wall
it hurts every time i see the sword at a
wall
well you talk about the sound
or just me being bad that i hit that i
hit it
[Music]
oh
you have to go back to the nexus and
talk to that blacksmith addict
okay okay i don't know how to get to the
nexus so
we're just going to have to wing it man
got the wing like a wing everything else
are you serious
are you getting it this time let's go
there's two of you over there don't
think i don't see that
i know there's two of you this one right
here
yeah don't think i didn't see that i
ain't that dumb
you see this armor's heavy
all right
now how do i know that this armor is
heavy or not is it so this weight
let me see what my armor weighs
4.6 well that's the helmet
11.5 all right let's
all right so that's 9.6 that's like
medium armor right
is that what that is it's medium armor
i'm curious if that's the medium armor
it's the medium armor right
it's got to be the medium armor you want
to be under 50s to move fast what am i
at now
i'm at 49.5 does that count as 50
percent huh
i i i'm fast in these streets man this
is what i like this is the kind of role
that you gotta have to be superior
i just need armor to do it man
look at that dude came around the corner
ready to ready to mess me up
dude came around the corner preemptively
waiting to strike me
uh you would definitely see some
struggle ricky man you'll definitely see
some struggle
what was that i don't want to know what
he was trying to do to me
come down here
let's go
come on
[Music]
you go eat again
i kind of need whatever he drops he
always drops some good stuff
i gotta go for it yeah see
that was worth it that was worth the
drop the number will be red if it's
heavy white if it's normal blue if it's
light
blue oh so you could be light hold up
okay
i wonder if i can get rid of like the
armor set can i
no
no because that just weighs way too much
oh my god x
i don't know how he lives that's a long
draw
i ain't done with them again
i'mma let them do
uh back to these dragons man
back to these dragons
i hear these dragons too oh those spear
people are here
look at you you knew i was there
some nonsense
oh what's the username for twitch it's
iron lord's podcast
i assume that you're talking about me
if you're talking about them i assume
it's the username that's on there
i don't know if it's exactly let me
bring up twitch let me bring up twitch
hold up twitch.tv
give me a second you guys i gotta look
up the twitch channel man
iron lords podcast
oh hold up let me make sure the desktop
audio is muted
guest podcast
so it says i'm playing destiny on there
by the way
that's that's not true that's false not
playing destiny
and to be honest with you guys i have no
clue how to change that
so i'm going back to youtube where i
belong
i don't belong on twitch i'm going back
to youtube
uh yes i'm playing on a monitor
where's this dragon
[Applause]
dragon let me down why didn't he do the
breathing the fire thing
come on breathe the fire
you taking forever to breathe that fire
does he ever get tired or is he just
gonna keep
trying to catch me on fire
did he leave
i think he's coming back he is
i think i have to do timing at the run
i gotta do it when he does that second
one and he runs
is he coming back i don't think he's
coming back
i think he's done no he's coming back
breathe your fire thank you
[Applause]
is he doing again
[Applause]
oh he's doing it again
[Applause]
no that fire there
hmm
yolo
dragon can't even take on
whoa
look look i was scared of the dragon
breathing fire
you don't have to get off my back if you
felt like i
shouldn't be scared of a dragon
breathing fire
i have every right to be scared of a
dragon what is that
what was that
whew
oh
oh
i feel like i gotta go this way for the
maybe there's a checkpoint somewhere
i'm
ah
man i hate those people they get right
through you man
what is this
great okay so the late moon is the one i
want to use last
okay
i'm gonna let that go through iron mike
i'm gonna let you
slander me and say i'm fixing to die
here you're probably right
i'm kind of worried about my sword i'm
not gonna lie
oh oh god oh the blobs what are those
they got a helmet on
oh it's got a shield
whoa
what's up jason been a while since i see
you in a chat jason
those blobs got shields on them man they
got shields on them there's another one
oh and they throw
[ __ ] at you okay okay
so i gotta run behind these blobs
i got you
gotta run behind him
congratulations
oh here's another one okay
oh that's the first boss all right
i'm debating if i should fight the boss
right now because i do got to be at the
gym
in 30 minutes and it's a 15 minute drive
from where i am
where i currently reside it is a 15
minute drive
so i'm trying to decide if i should
fight him one time for your guys's
amusement
or get ready for the gym like i told
myself i'm going to be
so i think i'm going to get ready for
the gym
it saved this for the first
couple minutes of my next stream i don't
know what i'm gonna start streaming
these
don't ask
so let me go ahead and go back to this
little nexus thing i think that's how
you get to the nexus
fight the boss now oh my god
if i would have died that i had been
very upset
look here's my thing with you guys i'm
trying
to be better i'm trying to go work out
daily
i'm sore eighty percent of my life now
and you guys want me to already
choose the game over working out
i'ma fight him one time for the culture
okay
one time
whew
i know it sounds like i'm doing
something stupid right now i know you
guys don't
understand why i'm backtracking it is
perfectly fine you don't have to
understand why i'm doing stuff
i don't know how to get to the nexus
i don't got a lot of time someone put in
the uh just
uh put in there how to get to the nexus
all right what'll it be then
okay put in there i had to get to the
nexus
you can't until you beat the first boss
so they people tell me i can't get to
the next and start beat the first boss
okay so i gotta fight him so screw that
i'm going out here and spitting all my
souls on nonsense
because chances are i'm not going to
beat him the very first time and i'm not
going to lose
all these souls
it's not happening
i'm going to the boss
calm yourself
i will be at the boss momentarily
oh you just have to die
i don't know look i'm going down
all of this i have no clue what this
boss looks like
we're gonna do it though we we're gonna
blind fight him
i got about 15 minutes
then i got to be out that door
i will not be looking at the chat you
have to deal with it
uh
are they separating
ow oh so they're just going to keep
throwing these imaginary spheres at me
okay
so i think the green thing is what i
want to aim for
uh
oh you trying to trap me
not happening
[Music]
it doesn't seem like these things around
him
regenerate
it seems like they they go in front of
them and they leave behind them clear
ow
[Music]
um
hello death mobile
[Music]
[Music]
uh
i think i got him
he's weak on the on this side now
oh
all right so how how do
how do i go to the nexus
that's a cool little unique boss though
i like that
coordinator little neat boss
oh so now these things are going to be
normal
ow oh so i got my full health back
ow touch the fire
oh the nexus there we go i'm an idiot
next to the bottom option touch the
stick all right
look man i didn't know i didn't know
oh welcome back
oh what is going on with this channel
awaits the above
i'm on the lord i appreciate it uh black
ronald i appreciate it
the monumental will explain the nexus to
thee
not gonna kill myself iron mike i don't
trust you
it seemed like she said go to the very
top
so profile
i don't know what that means
is this like a save file
okay so i can go farther up
what is this
[Music]
nah brav i usually i don't like playing
these with other people
but uh i could definitely play this
later after i beat the game
i don't like playing co-op with people
man how big is this cathedral
well what is this
pretty sure don't fool me look i gotta
be fast man
what is this is this other people
yeah it's jim tom i gotta figure i gotta
save first then
i'll go to the gym
uh
in the talk with the orange light
i think i'm not i don't think i'm in the
right place
that
where is this chick
[Music]
no go down someone told me to go up
the chick told me to go up
to the balcony okay i think that's where
i am is the balcony
let me see here you gotta guys gotta
remember there's like a delay
you gotta remember that let's go to the
other side i feel like
they want me to jump off that but i'm
very
nervous we have long awaited you slayer
of demons
the little monks
we have long awaited you slayer of
demons
i there is a tale i wish to tell you
all right
the distant past under benevolent rule
the world was united owing to the soul
arts
until a lust for power caused the
awakening
of the old one across the land
seat a colorless deep fog and the world
faced extinction
at the hands of the demons
[Music]
yet only after the loss of innumerable
souls
and most of the world lost
and raised by the fog
in order to mend the fabric of what land
still remained
we entrusted six leaders with six
precious
arch stones one to the king
of a small yet industrious land
one to the king of the borrowers
underground so let me guess i gotta go
get all of these things
one to the wise queen of the great ivory
tower
one to the chieftain of lost and
ill-fortuned souls
one to the shaman of the tempest
worshipping
shadowmen and the last to the great
giants of the northern lands
the chains were placed in the
fringelands that survived
we contained the old one here below the
nexus
so the old one is gonna be the last boss
am i
am i getting that right we became
monumentals
half-living sentinels of the fabric of
reality
alas the other monumentals have perish
and only i remain
[Music]
oh
hello hey what's up
yeah yeah um i'm about to leave here in
about five minutes
all right that's fine i'll be there in
about five minutes
alright peace
all right you guys how do i save
now it is your turn how do i save
the old one back to its slumber and seal
it away
for all eternity
if not
i thought the thing was gonna keep
saying something
did it auto save because i gotta get to
the gym
you guys are tripping having me up here
this late man
all right so
what i'll do is i will stream this
probably next monday or tuesday
after the podcast i'll only play this on
stream
uh you know even i only play it on
stream for right now
that's as far as we'll go for right now
but uh appreciate everyone camera by man
we had almost like 70 something
it was it was a good stream i would
definitely be doing this a little bit
more often
you guys have a good day man